[Music]
you have
hey everybody the incredibles is back if
you didn't know they're doing a sequel
to The Incredibles it's coming out after
Deadpool to next June is like June 15th
I think is when it's dropping and if you
haven't seen it you absolutely have to
watch The Incredibles in the way that
Kevin Conroy's animated Batman is one of
the best Batman portrayal of all time
The Incredibles is one of the best
superhero movies of all time it just
happens to be animated so we will have
been 14 years since the first film drop
which I know it sounds crazy but the
first film came way before Marvel phase
1 way before that first iron man movie
blew everything up even before
Christopher Nolan's Dark Knight trilogy
so in the way that movies like Deadpool
have started parodying the genre like
making fun of all superhero movies
movies in general Deadpool 2 will
continue to do that Incredibles did that
way back in the early 2000s it just been
so long that people don't talk about the
film as much but just to explain what's
going on with the sequel within the
world of the film it's only been a
little while so even though it's been 14
years in real life Incredibles 2 is only
gonna pick up a little bit after the
first movie ends so when the movie picks
up they still don't know jack Jack has
powers like they're going to find out
through the course of the movie that's
kind of what this teaser is telling you
like holy crap you have powers this is
great what are the actual powers that
we've seen Jack Jack manifests it should
basically been every power you could
possibly imagine so I'm guessing that
he's either replicating someone else's
powers or it's kind of a Franklin
Richards situation where he can just
create new things in his mind like he
just feels like a new power so he
automatically has it like there are
certain superheroes that can manifest
any power that they want there was the
final battle from the first film where
we see him morph into a demon he goes
full firestorm he transforms himself
into complete metal just
himself incredibly heavy he can slip
himself through the molecules of
substances the way the flash phases
through things so he phases into this
area here before he gives off his heat
vision he gives up another heat bursts
he gives off some lightning so obviously
they're just gonna be using him for a
lot of comedy during the film hope you
like the baby Groot of the film like
someone who's really cute but is crazy
powerful and doesn't know how to control
their powers so it just winds up being
really funny but pretty much all of the
main actors are coming back samuel
l.jackson is going to come back to do
Frozone they haven't said anything about
who the villains going to be they've
been super secretive about this and Brad
Bird has been working on a Ferb I think
about the past four years or so the only
new cast members we know about are Bob
Odenkirk and Catherine Keener but we
don't know who they're playing so we
don't know who's the big bill into the
movie is going to be the only minor
change they made to the original family
is is that because the actor who did the
voice for the son is now way too old
they just had to recast him but other
than that everybody's the same they blew
up their house at the end of the last
movie when Syndrome was trying to steal
Jack Jack so their new house in the
movie will be half superhero lair half
regular house in the sort of swap roles
a little bit and because Bob got in so
much trouble
at his last day job Helen is the one
that has the day job now he stays at
home then once everybody gets back from
school and work they moonlight as
superheroes but I think part of the idea
is is you've followed the logic of the
first film so what happened is is there
used to be a lot of superheroes chasing
around a lot of super villains like you
would see in Gotham like Batman gives
rise to a lot of villains but then in
the backstory of this world before that
first movie superhero sort of went out
of vogue or they were all killed so
there was just a period where a lot of
superheroes went into retirement so I
think the idea is is that now that
they're back out doing superhero stuff
that a bunch of other villains will
start popping up Batman style so in
addition to whoever the big bat ends up
being they'll probably a bunch of
smaller villains popping up for them to
take down in really hilarious ways but
let me know in the comments what's your
favorite moment from the original movie
and what'll probably happen is is
they'll release the full trailer
sometime early next year so that's when
we'll probably actually find out who the
villain is but I still think that
capes montage is probably one of the
wittiest takedowns of a superhero movie
ever like you know everybody thinks
about capes Superman it's great
it looks very iconic but Edna mode just
pokes so many holes in the logic of
needing to wear a cape you'll remember
Thunderhead tall storm powers nice man
good with kids listen 15:58
well another day say when his cape
snagged on a missile Thunder head wasn't
the brightest balsam April 23rd 57
kicked off in a jet turbine express
elevator diner guy snag on paper
splashdown sucked into a vortex
but the thing they've done since then is
they've actually explained the logic of
why Superman wears a cape like it
actually does help him fly just a little
bit but it is kind of hilarious because
he's so overpowered like why would you
need a cape if you're that powerful
but speaking of capes I'm gonna be
posting my spoilery Justice League
review next obviously I have a bunch of
Easter egg videos to get through so make
sure you subscribe to get everything if
you're just finding me for the first
time but while you wait for everything
click here to rewatch that Deadpool 2
trailer and you can click here for the
brand new teaser for the four-night
crossover thank you so much for watching
everybody stay awesome
I'll see you guys